you were the first male star massive  male star to pose nude  you did it in Cosmopolitan magazine it  blew people's minds it really that is a  cultural touchstone it it just surprised  people so much what's the touchstone you  put it that way it's unpleasant were you  surprised by the reaction first of all  you must have been terrified to do it uh  I was totally I was so drunk you're  drunk in that Oh plastered and I started  drinking the very early in the morning I  went out there and they said now the  first scene you know you'll be doing  so-and-so such as such that I said wait  a minute women you said I was just gonna  be lying on the couch and the guy said  yeah but we got to have something before  that I said I'm not taking my clothes  off I'll come in nude and throw it off  and then you roll yeah surprisingly he  did that and I I threw the robe off and  I went yeah and I'm sad to say I have  very small hands  [Laughter]  [Applause]  No oh my god  [Laughter]  you